et l'ordre du jour appelle la question
orale de Madame Catherine procasscia
monsieur le ministre de l'économie et
des
finances merci monsieur le Président
bonjour monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues ma question monsieur amamon
porte sur un sujet qui est au cœur de
votre actualité puisqu'il porte sur
l'assurance mais sur un point
particulier de l'assurance sur la hausse
de la tarification des assurances
automobiles pour les conductrices euh
suite à la décision de la Cour de
justice européenne euh chacun de sait
statistiquement seul un/ers des
accidents automobiles implique des
conductrices et la plupart du temps ce
sont des simples accrochages de voitures
et non des accidents corporels
impliquant des personnes c'est pour
cette raison que les
femmes jusqu'à présent bénéficiaient
d'un tarif préférentiel sur les
assurances automobiles malheureusement
dans un souci
d'égalitarisme excessif
la Cour de justice européenne a jugé que
cette pratique était discriminatoire et
a contraint les assureurs français à
appliquer le même tarif aux assurés quel
que soit leur sexe et de mettre fin en
décembre 2012 à une tarification donc
qu'ils ont qualifié de
discriminatoire la Fédération
françaisees des sociétés d'assurance il
y a à la fin de l'année dernière avait
précisé que les assurur
respecterait les nouvelles règles et
qu'il les appliqueront donc dès la
tarification de 2013 euh selon certaines
analyses les conductrices pourraient
voir augmenter leur tarifs de 4 à 50 %
en fonction de leur âge euh et c'est
particulièrement préjudiciable pour les
jeunes conductrices puisque les jeunes
conducteurs ont toujours une
tarification plus élevé compte tenu de
l'incidence des accidents euh mal mal
heureusement vous le savez de plus en
plus d'automobilistes roulent déjà sans
être assuré en raison du coût de leur
contrat et particulièrement les jeunes
j'aimerais donc savoir Monsieur le
Ministre ce que vous comptez faire pour
éviter que les nouvelles primes
d'assurance amènent les femmes mais
particulièrement les jeunes femmes à
venir grossir le stock des
automobilistes qui conduisent sans
assurance en outre le respect de cette
décision devrait théoriquement se
traduire par une diminution des prix des
hommes puisque il y avait une
compensation entre le tarifs des hommes
et des femmes comptez-vous réaliser des
contrôles afin de vérifier l'application
de cette disposition afin que si les
femmes en patissent les hommes puissent
en bénéficier quelles seront monsieur le
ministre si vous pouvez me le dire les
moyen mise en œuvre je vous en remercie
merci monsieur le
ministre merci madame la sénatrice
Catherine procassia je voudrais vous
faire une réponse très précise sur cette
question des tarifs des assurances et de
ces distinctions qui existaient entre
les tarifs pratiqués pour les femmes et
et pour les hommes en vous faisant un
point assez complet sur la réalité
aujourd'hui de la fréquence des
accidents mais surtout de la
sinistralité puisqueen réalité j'auraai
l'occasion de vous le dire à partir de
ces données statistiques la sinistralité
des accidents causés par les hommes est
beaucoup plus importante que celle causé
par les femmes
en l'occurrence les dernières
statistiques disponibles relatives aux
différences tarifaires entre les hommes
et les femmes en assurance automobile
qui ont été communiqué par l'Association
française de l'assurance qui regroupe la
FFSA et le GMA sur l'année 2011 indique
que la population des assurés se
féminise puisqueen effet alors qu'elle
ne représentait que moins d'un/art des
souscripteurs d'assurance automobile en
1989 elle représente aujourd'hui en 2011
plus du tiers de l'ensemble des contrats
d'assurance automobile ces données
indiquent également qu'en 2011 la
fréquence des accidents causés par des
conductrices dépasse de 8 % celle des
accidents imputables à des conducteurs
mais même si les accidents causés par
les conductrices sont un peu plus
fréquents ces accidents sont moins
graves et le coût moyen des sinistres
est moindre de 8 %. techniquement ces
deux effets se compensent de plus en
plus et on constate une tendance à la
convergence des primes théorique
nécessair à couvrir les dommages
matériels et corporels subis lors d'un
accident pour un véhicule entre les
hommes et les femmes en 2011 les
paramètres techniques étaient ainsi peu
différents entre les hommes et les
femmes pour les conducteurs qui ont plus
de 5 ans de permis il demeure toutefois
un écart de sinistralité entre les
hommes et les femmes lorsqu'on se
concentre sur la population des
conducteurs débutant pour les
conducteurs ayant moins de 2 ans de
permis le coût total des sinistres
causés par les hommes est encore
supérieur de 36 % à ceux causé par les
femmes le différentiel était de 88 % en
2009 C différence s'amenuise très
significativement au-delà de 2 ans de
permis différence de 16 % entre 2 et 5
ans de permis et quasi équilibre au-delà
de 5 ans ainsi les statistiques montrent
donc qu'au-delà de 5 ans de permis le
sexe du conducteur n'influe plus sur la
tarification technique l'arrêt de la
Cour de justice européenne Test Achat du
1er mars 2011 impose une égalité entre
les hommes et les femmes en matière de
tarifs et prestation d' urence à compté
du 21 décembre 2012 cette jurisprudence
a été transposée en droit français dans
le délai requis par un arrêté du 18
décembre 2012 en tenant compte des
lignes directrices de la Commission
européenne de décembre 2011 qui ont
expliciter cet arrêt notamment en ce qui
concerne la notion de discrimination
entre les hommes et les femmes prohibé
par cet arrêt la Commission européenne a
bien précisé que si les différenciations
tarifaires selon le sexe sont prohibé en
assurance à compte du 21 décembre 2012
les assureurs demeurent autorisés à
utiliser d'autres facteurs de risque
corrélés au sexes pour déterminer leur
tarifs j'ouvre les guillemets dès lors
qu'il s'agit bien de facteur de risque
réel fermé les guillemets pour les
contrats conclus à comptter du 21
décembre 2012 il en résulte que les
assureurs qui restent libres des tarifs
qu'il proposent ne peuvent utiliser le
sexe du conducteur comme facteur de
tarification mais demeurent autorisés à
avoir recours à d'autres critères de
tarification selon les profils des
assurés en particulier des jeunes
conducteurs même indirectement corrélés
au sexes comme par exemple le type de
véhicule son ancienneté la fréquence et
la nature de son usage plus généralement
l'évolution de la tarification en
fonction du coefficient de réduction de
majoration le bonus malus automobile
permet d'adapter le montant de la prime
à la sinistralité effective du titulaire
du contrat la direction du contrôle des
pratiques commerciales de l'ACP chargé
de veiller au respect des règles
destinées à assurer la protection des
clientèles pourra veiller à ce que les
tarifs pratiques en assurance automobile
soit conforme à la réglementation et ne
discrimine pas les catégories d'assuré
au-delà de cette question de la
différence de tarif et des réponses que
je j'ai pu vous donner je veux aussi
indiquer que dans la loi consommation
nous avons prévu de faire en sorte de
permettre le renouvellement des contrats
au-delà de la première année euh à la
date choisie par l'assurée de manière à
mettre davantage d'élasticité sur le
marché des assurances obligatoires je
pense à la MRH mais aussi à l'assurance
automobile qui permettra aux assurés en
général je l'espère de pouvoir
bénéficier grâce à une concurrence
accrue sur ce secteur d'une baisse des
primes ce qui leur permettra pour ces
dépenses obligatoires qui pèsent 5 % de
leurs dépenses mensuelles de voir leur
pouvoir d'achat augmenter voilà madame
la sénatrice merci Monsieur le Ministre
madame
procassia merci monsieur le ministre de
ces précisions et d'éléments quelque peu
rassurant en tout cas s'agissant des
jeunes conducteurs et des jeunes condu
rice même si je ne suis pas certaine que
c'est ça qui va conduire les jeunes à
s'assurer
davantage simplement me viennent de de
remarques bon vous avez évoqué votre
prochain le texte qui va bientôt arriver
au Sénat sur la consommation vous dites
que les assurances auto c'est 5 % moi
les statistiques que j'ai c'est 3 % dans
le budget des dépenses et puis je ne
crois pas que la résiliation soit la
solution à une éventuelle discrimination
mais ceci est un autre débat et nous
l'aurons effectivement dans l'hémicycle
le les facteurs de risque que vous
introduisez euh enfin que les assureurs
peuvent introduire compte tenu de des
éléments de la Cour de justice
européenne me paraissent être plus
proche effectivement du métier de
l'assurance et des statistiques euh que
des principes généraux euh mais surtout
en vous écoutant vient une inquiétude
c'est-à-dire que si on ne peut plus
faire de distinction entre les hommes et
les femmes il va falloir revoir toutes
les grilles de mortalité pour
l'assurance vie et là aussi ça va être
un chantier considérable et c'est aussi
un chantier dans lesquel les femmes vont
perdre